c'est dans l'hémicycle du palais de la
source qui ont été accueillis les futurs
assistants familiaux agréés par le
conseil départemental
en effet avant la signature de leur
contrat les assistants familiaux ont pu
compter sur les professionnels du
service enfance et famille de la
collectivité afin d'obtenir des réponses
à leurs questions concernant leurs
nouvelles fonctions il ya eu des lettres
de candidature on se rend compte que
beaucoup sont déjà en fait dans des
activités professionnelles et qui en
même temps envie de faire le métier donc
d'asante familiale et ça va nécessiter
effectivement qu'on voit avec quelle bas
comment et quels choix et seront amenés
en fait à faire dans les mois à venir
pour pouvoir soit poursuivre cette
activité elle soit faire le choix du
continu l'autre métier les futurs
assistants familiaux vont désormais
devoir apprendre le métier et tout
mettre en place afin d'offrir le
meilleur accueil possible à l'enfant et
des ailes sont en fait déjà agréé donc
elles ont déjà l'agrément par contre le
challenge ça va être en fait au niveau
du stage de parts at war et haut niveau
donc donc pendant ces on va dire la
période d'essai et les deux années à
venir c'est vraiment s'immerger en fait
donc dans le métier d'assistant familial
est arrivé à appréhender les besoins des
enfants qu'elles vont accueillir et voir
comment ces enfants-là réagissent et
intérêts agissent en fait avec le milieu
familial et les propos enfants de la
sainte famille à devenir assistant
familial résonne pour certains comme une
véritable vocation et une réelle envie
d'aider l'autre malgré les difficultés
rencontrées dans ce métier les candidats
sont déterminés et souhaite réellement
s'engager dans leurs nouvelles
responsabilités
j'ai décidé d'être assistante familiale
étant donné étant dans une famille de
six enfants et mes parents étaient très
stricte se note est dit éducation pardon
et donc que moi mes enfants sont grands
j'ai un petit 10 ans et étant une
famille chrétienne
mon frère et diacres et on a toujours
aidé l'église de poids nous pourrons
pour moi j'avais envie d'être
un peu comme mon image et d aider ces
enfants là
pour leur éducation soit parfaite
et puis ici ainsi un peu de l'aide
sociale quoi